[Music]
are you excited for all the new games
releasing in March well if you're an
Xbox Live Gold subscriber you have a lot
more to be excited for thanks to the
announcement of Marches games with gold
lineup
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
keep up on every month's games with gold
xbox one gold subscribers get spooky
horror game layers of fear all month
while team-based shooter evolved becomes
available on March 16th and can be
claimed until April 15th as for Xbox 360
games subscribers can grab Borderlands 2
from March 1st to the 15th and heavy
weapon for March 16th to the end of the
month and don't forget that both of
those games are backwards compatible
with the Xbox one and those are your
March games with gold if you still
haven't grabbed project cars from
February's lineup then you have until
March 15th will keep you up to date as
the next month's allotment of free games
is revealed but for now why not check
out our video on the five things you
should know before playing the Ghost
Recon wildlands open beta